à l'urss et la corée du sud
n'entretenant pas de relations
diplomatiques des consultations avaient
eu lieu tout au long de la journée entre
la capitale coréenne tokyo washington et
moscou qui protestaient aussitôt contre
l'aspect anti soviétique que prenait
selon le kremlin les informations de
plus en plus précises glanés par les
différents centres de renseignement
maintenant les faits par est établi
bruno le dreff ces images datent de ce
matin les familles des passagers
attendaient toujours à l'aéroport de
séoul des nouvelles du boeing 747 de
korean airlines mais l'avion ne sait
donc maintenant a disparu mercredi vers
3 heures 30 heure locale
il venait de new york avec 269 personnes
à son bord et emprunter la route la plus
courte celle qui remonte d'abord vers le
nord pour profiter de la courbure du
globe terrestre au moment de son dernier
contact radio avec le contrôle de l'air
japonais l'appareil se trouvait à 180 km
au nord ouest de la presqu'île de nomura
il volait à 11000 mètres d'altitude
vraisemblablement en pilotage
automatique
quelques instants après les écrans radar
japonais perd 200 grammes mais un
appareil d'allant d'identifier volant à
une altitude de 10000 mètres est repérée
à 200 kilomètres au nord de vannes
canaille et puis disparaît quelques
minutes plus tard juste après
l'apparition de chasseurs soviétiques
sur les écrans radar un moment on croit
que l'avion a été contraint de se poser
sur l'île soviétique de sakhaline donc
il aurait violé l'espace aérien
mais bientôt les autorités japonaise
annonce que l'avion a probablement été
abattue par des chasseurs soviétiques
une information confirmée d'abord par
les japonais puis par les américains
l'agent japonaise de défense et la
première affirmé avoir enregistré un
message entre la bad soviétique
militaire de sakhaline et un pilote
soviétique viser la cible
cible visée tirer feu on peut imaginer
ce qui s'est passé en regardant ces
mirages à l'exercice de tirs à moscou
dans un premier temps après la
déclaration officielle de washington